Tywin Lannister: Long ago, in the wintry North,
an army of demons emerged from beneath the
icy ground and spread darkness and despair
across the land.
Astride their monstrous spiders, flanked by
giants, they wreaked havoc on the innocent,
slaughtering thousands.
All hope was lost until the fearless warriors
of the first Night's Watch drove them back
into the wintry mountains and built a magic
wall to keep them from ever invading again.
These stalwart Brothers in black continue
to protect us even to this day from the evils
that lurk in the shadows.
An absurd lie, a fairy tale, spun by many
a wetnurse in the North.
To be sure, a giant wall does exist - a triumph
of engineering, perhaps, but not of "magic".
As for the Night's Watch, there may have been
a time, centuries ago, when there was prestige
and honor in the miserable, monastic life
of a Black Brother.
But now the Wall has become a glorified penal
colony, full of outcasts, criminals and assorted
ne’er-do-wells.
Sansa Stark: Unlike our southern rivals, the
Stark Kings of Winter didn't forge the North
into one kingdom for glory or gold (there
is little of either here), but to survive.
Alone in Westeros, the North remembered when
worse than dragons lay waste to armies.
Thousands of years ago, the sun set on the
realms of men, and the Long Night began.
A new race emerged from the ice and snow:
the White Walkers.
They demanded no crown, offered no terms,
spared no life, and the dead marched with
them.
With humanity facing extinction, a Stark sought
out the Children of the Forest, the most ancient
beings in Westeros, and convinced them to
ally with the men they'd once fought.
Together, the two races pushed the Walkers
back into the Land of Always Winter and sealed
it off from the Seven Kingdoms with the Wall,
three hundred miles of ice, stone, and earth
rising nearly seven hundred feet tall.
To guard it, they established the Night's
Watch, a brotherhood sworn to defend the living
from the dead, whose vows erase both titles
and crimes.
Viserys Targaryen: After the Long Night, the
North tried to forget it belonged to a continent.
Perhaps through pride, perhaps through sheer
ignorance.
You never can tell with the North.
Ygritte: "Swords in the darkness."
Aye.
The black brothers of the Night's Watch are
that at least.
When he lies down at night, he can't have
anybody to warm his frozen bed.
Well, not unless the crows like to "nest"
together.
You think he remembers the stories they told
him then?
About when the White Walkers woke in the Land
of Always Winter and how the Wall and the
Night's Watch were raised to stop them the
next time?
Never mind trapping us on the other side?
We Free Folk have our stories, too.
About how one of your king crows found something
cold in the woods with bright blue eyes.
How he brought her home, through your wall,
and declared himself "Night's King."
For thirteen years, he and his queen ruled
over his brothers, making sacrifices as black
as their cloaks.
Lucky for you southerners, the Free Folk rallied
to a King-Beyond-the-Wall, as we will when
need be, and marched on the ancient castle
he had taken as his own, the Nightfort.
With the help of the Starks, we killed the
demon and cleansed your precious watch.
And then they thanked us and kicked us back
across the Wall.
As you always have.
Jeor Mormont: "Night gathers, and now my watch
begins.
It shall not end until my death.
I shall take no wife, hold no lands, father
no children.
I shall wear no crowns and win no glory.
I shall live and die at my post.
I am the sword in the darkness.
I am the watcher on the Wall.
I am the shield that guards the realms of
men.
I pledge my life and honor to the Night's
Watch, for this night and all the nights to
come."
Legend tells of a winter that lasted a generation,
and of a vast and terrible darkness that fell
across the land.
It came to be known as the Long Night.
In the midst of this darkness, the White Walkers
emerged from the Far North.
With their armies of the dead, they waged
war against the living; laying waste to villages
and holdfasts; leaving terror and destruction
in their wake.
After years of brutal conflict and unbearable
loss, an alliance of the First Men and the
Children of the Forest managed to drive the
Walkers and their minions back into the frigid
northern wastelands from whence they came.
To prevent another invasion, the First Men
erected the Wall, a massive fortification
700 feet in height, stretching from the Frostfang
Mountains, in the west, to the Bay of Seals,
in the east.
It was a structure unlike any ever built.
Indeed, some maintain it could only have been
completed with the aid of giants, or using
the powerful magic of the ancient Children
of the Forest.
Men were required to guard and maintain it,
and thus the Night's Watch was born - a sworn
brotherhood tasked with defending the realms
of men against the dark forces that lay beyond.
Upon taking his vows, a Brother of the Night's
Watch serves for life.
It is a life of hardship and great sacrifice,
so the oath must not be taken lightly.
The punishment for desertion is death.
Maester Luwin: Joining the Night's Watch,
or "taking the black", is a singular honor
for any northerner.
For it was in the North, some 8,000 years
ago, that the First Men drove back the White
Walkers, erected the Wall, and established
the sworn brotherhood that would guard the
realm and its people from the dangers beyond.
Regrettably, the Night's Watch no longer commands
the widespread respect and admiration it once
did.
While House Stark and other houses in the
northern regions continue to recognize its
vital importance to the safety and stability
of the realm, this view is not shared by the
powerful houses of the southern kingdoms,
or their subjects.
Most regard the Watch as a misguided, obsolete
order made up of useless outcasts.
Admittedly, the current Night's Watch is a
shadow of its former glory.
Samwell Tarly: The maesters don't believe
in prophecy, with good reason.
The Children of the Forest supposedly could
see into the future, yet were surprised by
the First Men who nearly ended their race
and the Long Night, which nearly ended us
all.
Some Maesters posit that the Children's magical
sight was invented long after they vanished
from Westeros by singers hoping to thrill
peasant girls.
Not that most Maesters have much experience
in what does or doesn't do that.
The Three-Eyed Raven: War did not come to
Westeros with men.
In the dawn of days, the Children of the Forest
fought the giants.
But neither race sought to destroy the other
or lay claim to the continent.
They couldn't; the Children hunted and fought
with dragonglass arrows and spears, and the
giants had hold of the branches they pulled
from trees.
Nor could both races fill more than one of
the Seven Kingdoms of today.
But then the southern deserts coughed up a
new race, the First Men, who had crossed the
Narrow Sea over the Arm of Dorne.
The First Men had never seen weirwood, but
the Children had never seen bronze.
The dragonglass arrows glanced off the First
Men's shields, and their armor of woven bark
split beneath the First Men's swords.
As the war waged, the children resorted to
the one advantage they had, the magic of their
Old Gods.
Their greenseers enlisted direwolves and snow
bears, cave lions and eagles, mammoths, and
serpents.
In return, the First Men cut down and burned
every weirwood they could find, fearing that
the Children could spy on them through the
faces in the trees.
The Children became desperate.
Their greenseers called down the hammer of
waters to break the Arm of Dorne, destroying
the bridge that men crossed into Westeros,
and to flood the Neck to contain men to the
south.
But the First Men would not be stopped.
Fearing extinction, the Children combined
their powers for one last spell that would
save their people and their land from the
invaders.
By themselves, the Children were too few to
resist the onslaught, but if they could turn
men's numbers against them...
After hundreds of years of untold death and
destruction, the wisest heads of the Children
and the First Men finally prevailed.
The Children couldn't win this war, and the
First Men didn't want to win, fearing the
cost of victory.
Heroes and rulers on both sides met upon an
isle in the Gods Eye to form the Pact.
The Children gave up all the lands of Westeros
save for the deep forests, and the First Men
swore that they would no longer cut down the
weirwoods.
Thus ended the Dawn Age and began the Age
of Heroes.
Yet after the dawn must come the night.
The great evil that the Children unleashed
in the war returned centuries later, and only
an alliance between the Children and men defeated
it.